in our opening show of the year we
talked about the central problem of
american politics which is that our
leaders have lost sight of the point of
being in charge
their goal should be simple strong
american families
anything that makes it harder to form
strong families they ought to be against
it's not complicated
judging by the response we got a lot of
you agree with that the piece resonated
more than anything we've done in the
last two years
in washington though it wasn't very
popular one writer at national review
suggested we are peddling something
called
victimhood populism that's missing the
point
populism is never the goal it's the
symptom
populism is what you get when you blow
off the country's problems
for so long that voters feel they have
to punish the people in charge to get
their attention
populism is a smoke alarm ignore it and
the place burns down
on the left meanwhile the response was
just as predictable they screamed
bigotry which is always what they do
when they don't want you to talk about
something
in this case they accused us of sexism
we dared to talk about the role of
falling male wages in the destruction of
the american family
that's not allowed okay but let the
record reflect that we're not the first
ones to notice this phenomenon
there's at least one well-known
politician who thought deeply about this
more than a decade ago
in fact wrote an entire book on the
subject see if you can guess who that
was
all right time's up it was elizabeth
warren
back in 2003 warren was still a harvard
professor
that year she published a book written
with her daughter entitled the two
income trap why middle class mothers and
fathers are going broke
the central thesis of the book was that
the mass entry of mothers into the
workforce has been a disaster for
families and most of all for women
mothers who work have to spend far more
time away from their kids
which for many isn't liberating so much
as it's deeply sad
companies love it of course because more
workers means cheaper labor
but middle-class families they don't
seem happier or more secure than they
were a generation ago
if anything much less as warren points
out you'd think families would be much
richer with two parents working
that hasn't happened virtually all the
income gains have been consumed in an
arms race to maintain the status quo
most things in american life are cheaper
than they were 50 years ago
except for the things that middle-class
families need most those are all much
more expensive
health care day care college tuition
housing in places with good public
schools
buying those things now requires two
incomes rather than one
that puts a strain on families in which
both parents work it absolutely crushes
single parent households warren puts it
this way
quote a generation ago a single
breadwinner who worked diligently and
spent carefully could assure his family
a comfortable position in the middle
class
but the frenzied bidding wars fueled by
families with two incomes
changed the game for single-income
families as well pushing them
down the economic ladder to keep mom at
home the average single
income family must forfeit decent public
schools in preschools
health insurance and college degrees
leaving themselves and their children
with a tenuous hold on middle class
dreams
such pressures have taken these women
out of the home and away from their
children
and simultaneously made family life less
not
more financially secure today's middle
class mother is trapped
she can't afford to work and she can't
afford not to
end quote now just to restate this is
not a press release from the mennonites
or a position paper for some christian
right think tank
this was written fairly recently by
senator elizabeth warren of
massachusetts the same one the hero to
the left
later in the book and we read it warren
lays out the long-term consequences of
an economic system that requires both
parents to work
more families go broke this increases
the rate of domestic abuse divorce
and broken homes some people simply
decide not to have children at all
and warren's response to that is
striking again another quote from
elizabeth warren
many view parenthood as nothing more
than another lifestyle choice
not so different from joining a commune
or developing a passion for windsurfing
but it isn't true for society at large
what happens to a nation that rewards
the childless
and penalizes the parents if
middle-class men and women stop making
that parental lifestyle choice
who will care for them in their old age
who will pay taxes build infrastructure
and keep the economy afloat
and most important who will populate the
great middle class
of america's future end quote again and
we can't say this enough
elizabeth warren wrote that not in 1936
but in 2003 the modern era we had jet
planes and frozen yogurt
elizabeth warren said that out loud
nobody seemed to mind
she'd never say that today it's not
allowed like so much else that is true
and important
we'd love to talk to warren about her
book anytime obviously she won't come on
she can't talk about the things that she
believed 10 years ago
no modern democrat can they can't say
that protecting and encouraging married
two-parent families ought to be the goal
that's not their base anymore but we can
talk about it and we will and we will
celebrate
elizabeth warren and anyone else who
will join us in that conversation
this is not a partisan issue it is all
that matters